[Music]  she's et social study a quick look at  what the Stars are posting online  [Music]  just one  one year after the death of legendary  artist David Bowie Iman is sharing a  beautiful tribute to her late husband a  double rainbow across the New York City  skyline captioned bowi forever - I can  live without cookies and potato chips  the one thing I cannot live without  easier the emotional hit series this is  us finally returns to NBC Tuesday night  maybe more shared at this sweet pick  from set with co-star milo ventimiglia  when i watch it yeah I definitely feel  that weight of being a human being and I  feel that weight of hopefulness another  moment from the gloves red carpet Mandy  Moore holding hands with her boyfriend  Taylor Goldsmith captured by Minka Kelly  and Kesha is sharing snaps of her  brand-new ink the tattoo of a pink whale  captioned psychedelic whales are slowly  covering my entire body  [Music]  you